before you watch Matt do this seek
discomforts last drop of 2018 is finally
out this is by far the biggest and the
widest selection of designs and items
we've ever had and since it's for the
holidays we're gonna have an epic
surprise for one of you so if you guys
ordered within the next three days
you're gonna receive a form asking you
what your biggest dream is gonna choose
one of you to help you accomplish
whatever that dream might be so wherever
you are in the world if you order within
the next three days you might have a
chance at having us help you accomplish
one of your biggest dreams which will be
an episode which will be up on yes they
enjoy the rest of the video that's it
there comes a point in one's life where
we feel the burning desire to challenge
ourselves to overcome something that
both our mind and our body are begging
us not to do and everybody around us
think is crazy it's different for
everyone for some it might be facing a
fear for others it might be opening up
about our past but for Matt this month
it's been overcoming the biggest
physical challenge of his life by
competing in a half ironman
with only 30 days to train form it on a
scale from one to ten how prepared will
you see or talk to this done it you
throw up yourself like you cry never
felt this nervous about anything I'm
like what everybody's been telling me
about it and have scary and difficult
that is just like you sure you want to
do it he was what a Half Ironman entails
so I mean one point two miles that
hopping on a bike for 56 miles and after
those five hours of racing run 13
miles equivalent half of a marathon now
that's not a typical race for amateurs
especially with less than a month of
training he knows nothing about what he
should eat I've never done tried love
before I thought anybody liked my
training or my nutrition or anything
what do you know about my race he knows
nothing about his gear so this is not
your typical robot it's decided to go
straight and he certainly never put on
the proper attire for it 29 days away
and you're putting on a cycling outfit
for the first time this looks like a
joke I don't think that's the right way
that's for your yeah it's been on my
list for so long and I put in the
beginning this year I'm like this year
I'm doing and I signed up for this one
and about a month ago because I hadn't
really trained at all
I told tomorrow's like listen I know I
signed up but it's fine like I just
won't do it
tomorrow is like dude no you're doing
this half ironman
it's amazing to have friends that just
push you when you just don't want to do
it to just actually make you do what you
set out to accomplish and as he pushed
through it only seemed to be getting
worse
most people do actually for doing the
70.3
they're all training to do 70.3 yeah
guys practice for the same race like
three times as long and then
[Music]
as he was beginning his training Matt
realized that doing this alone was
making this 10 times harder
so 17 days away from the race Matt
thought he asked one of our bravest
theists friends around Connor if he'd be
insane enough to join him on his crazy
journey twice as long next to each other
Connors here and I have some news for
him so apparently without knowing a
sentence up for one of the hardest half
ironmans in the world well I was
designed by Navy SEALs the first six
miles of the run are in sand and lights
and probably there's the cutoff time so
you can't be too slow either otherwise
you're just qualified automatically yeah
you see the sign is up for the only one
that you have to compete you buy a
ticket no you haven't bought right now
go do it right now you know why I'm
saying so like yeah after I found out
that it's basically a Hunger Games
situation so the reason kind of bring
you in this is to make myself feel
better there's got to be a guy behind
the draft off each other on the pilot of
course now you can't run or bike with
any music why don't you not have run the
music if you were tortured and after the
run there's a the barbed wire section
people will be cheering your name oh god
the paramedics in the ambiences voice
connor everybody who's so jacked except
for us
absolutely terrified
I look back and I just you
we're already so undertrained
a key components to overcoming and a
possible journey is to find a mentor
someone more experienced that can guide
you and during math preparation our
manager Zack reached out for help to the
ultimate Ironman runner rich troll who
magically four days before the race
agreed to meet ritual is what you could
call a beast at 40 he was 50 pounds
overweight and realized that he needed
to completely change his life after a
few transformative years to accomplish
what most people he impossible getting
ranked in the top 25 fittest men in the
world by men's fitness
he completed five Ironman races
back-to-back in less than a week and
finished in the top ten with a 320 mile
endurance race around Hawaii we could
not think of a better person from Matt
and Connor to talk to for a person who's
entering the triathlete world with their
first race what tips would you give in
terms of both your mental state your
physical state like how to prepare
yourself how long until the race all
right so with four days to go it's all
about mindset and truly the determining
factor in how you'll do whether you
finish or not is completely up here it
really is about the mind the mind will
shut down long before the body I wish I
came up with this I didn't it's from
somebody called David Goggins who was a
big inspiration to me he has this great
saying which is when you think you're
done you're completely cooked and you
can't go one step further realize that
you've only tapped into about 40 percent
of what you're truly capable of we're
all capable of so much more than we
allow ourselves to believe and I think
most people are walking around tip
toeing atop vast reservoirs of untapped
potential and it's only when you allow
yourself to get uncomfortable put
yourself in a precarious situation where
you really don't know what's going on
like you guys are doing that you're able
to connect with that and realize that we
can all do things that we thought were
while previously I mean that's certainly
my experience I never thought that I
would be able to do the things that I've
done but it's only in the trying that
you have that journey of self-discovery
that once you realize like hey I did
this thing I didn't think I could do it
starts to expand your awareness of
what's possible so if you were to
actually give advice to someone who has
portrayed anything like this before they
wanted to start now what kind of like
good boys would you give them to just
began what I see in a lot of people is
analysis paralysis like they're
interested in doing a triathlon or
running a marathon and they spend an
unbelievable amount of mental energy
evaluating which bike to get and what
kind of shoes are right if they're
almost fear tactics to prevent you from
just doing it everybody has a pair of
shoes if you don't just go out and run
barefoot that's it you don't have to
overcomplicate it the more you create
momentum around it all of those other
questions that you have will get
answered in time but the important thing
is to be in action rather than in
indecision
[Music]
yeah thank you guys I don't know it was
now 2 days before the race and believe
it or not they were just about to bike
run and swim all in one day for the
first time isn't the first day you do
the feet together
[Music]
come on boys vegan Donuts come on
what are you doing this for come on baby
[Music]
Oh God
at the finish line that's what we'll be
crossing today hopefully icon it oh yeah
you'll be carrying me but we'll be
crossing it
very nervous now
everybody is so focused everybody has
their system down meanwhile I'm just
trying to figure out where to put my
space it's crazy
it's finally here you know but giving a
Half Ironman on my lists of dreams and
goals for the last four years and I just
haven't done it and had made up all
these excuses the fact that I'm here
just blows my mind like if I cross that
finish line dude it's gonna crazy
getting shivers everyone so well prepare
to get at em for this I think we just
get through the swim it's gonna be the
most enjoyable day of our life
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
right after this is the transition to
about 3 to 4 hours of biking and like
the pack of 800 they're about in the
middle it's just pretty damn good for
barely having
[Music]
like animals everybody's like going at
each other getting rotten deceased
Wallace swinging I cannot help but think
there's no place I'd rather be right now
she's doing this survive it he's young
hyped I have the real race begins that
was faster than I expected but we'll see
about this bike ride I'll be way long
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
very fast
my ask me who was four laps I was
answering back tumor I think today and I
was to closing the guy said to narrow
his draft maybe draft off each other on
the pilot of course not my god
are you feeling I don't know I'm gonna
do this run dude how are you legs
totally totally that house so long you
were biking for three and a half hours I
know did the first loop in kana and I or
both life do we actually have four more
of these I thought we had made a mistake
that we that are so long
two dogs three we feed it when like no
my hands my feet are tingling so right
now they begin the six mile run on the
beach before they get the concrete
that way their rule is that we do not
stop no matter what better blisters like
Connor dying from the heat
walking away
excruciatingly got so funny now all the
voices in my head I say no Kim with good
we're gonna cheer them on with some
donut for the rest of our lives
feels so good
[Music]
as soon as I crossed that finish line
all the doubt all the fear all the
uncertainty gone and all that was left
was this overwhelming sensation this
realization that not only me but all of
us are capable of so much more than we
think
and the only way of truly finding out
what were made of is to seek discomfort
[Music]
for seek discomforts biggest drop to
date we wanted to do something very
unconventional instead of telling you
why we believe so much in the power of
wearing what you believe
we've decided to show you what the hype
has been all about see for the past six
months we've seen tens of thousands of
you refseq discomfort apparel all over
the world telling us about countless
stories of connection you've had with
like-minded people all starting with
someone being curious about what seek
discovered meant or represented so for
today's experiment we've decided to
create an environment for our community
to come together and seek some early
morning discomfort
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]